We're not here to say like Aubre's a
prophet or that God gives her dreams or
anything. Actually, Aubrey has some
really vivid dreams every night. I
don't. I go to sleep, I wake up, I don't
remember anything. If I take a nap, I
might have a dream. But
>> Aubrey can tell me dreams like a movie
every morning, and she'll be telling me
like, "Well, I was here for 12 years."
I'm [laughter]
like, "How do you have a dream about 12
years?
>> [snorts]
>> But um you know usually they don't
really seem to have any kind of
significance. Sometimes they're even bad
dreams, you know. Um they really they
just seem kind of random, you know, just
kind of life events or whatever.
>> But when she told me this dream,
immediately God was revealing things to
me through this dream. Like it's it's
not going to be a dream like this is how
the future's going to be, per se. It's
more symbolic like the book of
Revelation, like Daniel. God always
gives dreams in symbols. I mean, pe
people have a hard time understanding
that. They think there's really going to
be a harlot riding a seven-headed beast
and all this stuff, but every dream that
God gave in the Bible was symbolic. With
Joseph, there was stars bowing down
other stars. There was stalks of wheat
bowing down. There was skinny cows
eating fat cows. Daniel saw uh beasts
rising out of the ocean and it said that
the beasts were kingdoms and John saw a
woman standing on the moon clothed with
the sun and a harlot riding a
seven-headed dragon. All this is
symbolic.
So this dream is not like I saw a dream
into the future type thing, but more
um how we should be living what kind of
the signs of the times are now. And when
I told her that I was that God was
giving me all these impressions about
this dream, she was like, I don't know
about that. She she's not claiming like
I had a prophetic dream. No,
>> I'm telling her she had a prophetic
dream. And I shared this with my friend
and he slapped the table and was like,
"What? She doesn't see that this is
prophetic."
>> So, I was like, I think this would be
worth sharing even if it's just to kind
of pull out some biblical references and
ideas,
but it was a really cool dream. So, we
got some visuals to show you guys as she
shares the dream. But yeah, you should
share the dream and we'll discuss maybe
at the end what you think it's about.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. So, let's begin.
I had a dream starting with several of
my siblings and I and our friends, some
friends from church, some friends from
our growing up years from like public
school, some friends from Mikey's past
that were coming over. Everyone was
meeting with my family after so many
years or even for the first time. and
they were all being brought to meet my
parents at this table type scenario in
the living room
because they kind of have an open um
floor plan at their house anyway. And as
people would be brought to meet my
family,
um we weren't all sitting down
necessarily. We weren't all standing up.
We were just kind of all mingling around
in their their house. And it was about
man, it was crazy. like 30 35 40 people
there and um I just in my dream as each
person was introduced to my parents it
was almost as though
and I don't you know of course my
parents are not they're humans they're
they're nothing other than human but in
my dream it was it was as though they
were standing there almost as place of
God in some ways like because as the
first man came up to meet my parents.
This is a depiction of him. Um it was a
friend of Mikey's from the past.
And he or actually he still knows him,
but he um had a
has I guess a drinking problem and and
sometimes he does weed. And so these
kinds of of things that he needed to
turn over to God and need to give up in
his life started appearing around my
parents right in front of them and all
over their house. And
everyone that entered this house, stuff
like that would happen. their sins that
they were holding on to would appear
before my parents
right when they were meeting him or
them, I'm sorry, on like the tables or
the sides just like you're seeing here.
And everyone would get embarrassed and
grab those things up and start hauling
them outside as quickly as they could.
They' be like, "Excuse me, I have to get
this stuff. I'm going to throw it in the
dumpster." And there was a dumpster
outside that was quite large that was
like an incinerator dumpster. It was
really amazing in that way. And um so
that was the first guy who had that
happen. And then there was Mikey himself
who had struggled with this whole um I
guess
>> idolization
>> idolization of Marilyn Manson. So, a
bunch of those magazines of Marilyn
Manson started appearing on like the
magazine stand at my parents house and
where they have books. And
>> I do want to say
nobody knows of like a Marilyn Manson
magazine. You you don't go to the store
and buy a Marilyn Manson magazine. When
she said that, and she's never known
this about my past, I as a teenager in
high school had a collection of what you
might would call Marilyn Manson
magazines. They were Revolver, Hip
Parader. There were these metal
magazines, but he was on the front
cover. And that's the whole reason I had
the magazine was because he was on the
front cover and there was like a poster
inside of him and all these articles.
So, I literally had Marilyn Manson
magazines and she didn't know that.
>> I didn't even know they existed, but it
seemed that they were just appearing and
he was grabbing them up and and
apologizing. Everyone was apologizing
and just being like, "Excuse me, I've
got to get rid of this." So, he also
disposed of that and came back in the
house and everything was fine. And the
next person would stand up and Mikey has
depicted here, he struggled with porn.
And so, as he approached and began to be
introduced to my parents, my parents
wouldn't say anything, by the way. They
would just sit there and be introduced
and they never shamed anyone or was
like, "What's going on here?" But they
would just let it unfold. And this guy
just saw those porn CDs and and
magazines. Quite frankly, in the dream
it was magazines as well. Um
very quickly and started to grab them
and and take them out. And the next
person that stepped up was uh a woman
who was very into fashion. In fact, it
seemed to consume her life. And so she
started having Yeah, I guess her phone
go off. But there was
>> online shopping.
>> Yep. And she's very into into online
shopping and there were magazines
everywhere um also that appeared and it
was never in the same place for anybody.
But anyway, so she was embarrassed and
she decided to suddenly the moment just
take time to grab up all of those and
dispose of them. And I in my life have
struggled the most with music, hiphop
and rap music the most. Um I've shared
that a little bit on our channel, but
I'd given all of that up and some of my
favorite rappers and hiphop CDs started
appearing on the table. And don't get me
wrong, like I said, I've given that up.
Mikey given up what he'd given up a long
time ago. just we were all being made
aware that we were fallible. We still
are and where we came from and those who
were just being made aware of it. We're
coming and having like a a come to Jesus
moment. And so for me, I I grabbed it
all up and I disposed of it as well and
went back in the house and everyone was
starting to have a good time.
Then it just cut it cut straight to this
other dream. And in this dream, I was in
this big mall and we're all wearing
white and we were all looking at clothes
first. So this this isn't quite where we
were, but all of a sudden over the
loudspeaker,
it's um 2049 and they said that and
everyone started saying this is when
eating hour is. You need to everyone you
have to get to the eating what is it?
The cafeteria. And so I was like well
this is a mall. Why do we eat in a mall?
And and why in the cafeteria? Why does
everyone have to be there? You know, all
these feelings. But they ushered
everyone like they almost shut down all
the other areas of the mall
just to have everyone come to the
cafeteria. And no, 2049 has no
significance here. I don't know why it
was brought up and why I remember the
exact year. That usually doesn't happen
in my dreams at all. But
um so as we're going through cafeteria
line, I
I went through it backwards, by the way.
It had a beginning and an end, and you
couldn't get through
to the very beginning again very easily.
It was a very long line, buffet line.
And
let's just say, um I was looking for
I was so hungry. I was looking for
vegetables specifically. I love
vegetables and I was looking for a main
staple of a grain and like all these
things that were healthy. I wanted real
food and all I could find was chocolate
cake mo [clears throat] mainly in the
center of the room on a big table and
one vanilla cake
next to it with all the other chocolate
cake. And on the outskirts is where I
was trying to get to.
I just couldn't. It was like everyone
was going the opposite direction of me
because I was going the wrong way and
they didn't want you had to go through
the area.
If you have the main table and you have
the walking area around it and not much
else besides the corners of the room and
I was going checking all the corners
tables for real food.
They kept bumping into me and I just was
so frustrated because I wanted food and
I've never been into chocolate,
[laughter]
>> you know? I'm just not a chocolate
lover. Nothing was appealing to me. And
so cafeteria time started to dwindle
down. Like they were only open for one
or two hours and I was still looking
through the food. I was still looking
for real food. By the time I sat down, I
hadn't really found anything. I did get
I remember getting like three different
kinds of chocolate cake and one piece of
the vanilla cake and I sat down and
something just came over me. I saw
people that I knew suddenly that were
from church, from my growing up years
again, from public school, from charter
school, from different denominations,
all different kinds of denominations,
gossiping, especially un unfortunately
especially the people from church were
gossiping and cursing and slandering
each other and um there was plenty of uh
sexual innuendos and stuff going on.
Everyone is adults, by the way, just
like this picture. There were no
children, there were no babies, there
was nothing else in between. Everyone is
in white and everyone is adults. And um
it just bothered me because of all of
the corruption, the disgusting things
people were saying and how much they
were eating this. It was a huge piece of
chocolate cake just like you're seeing.
That's that's a really big piece by the
way, I think. And so they were eating it
like it was just amazing. And no one
else had real food. I had found nothing,
but I I did see that they had like a
fake risoto and they had other things.
And you're they had other foods, but no
one was eating it. And I it wasn't the
healthy version. Like I didn't want mac
and cheese. I'm sorry. I'm a healthy
health nut. So I didn't want to eat any
of the other crap that they had.
So
I sat down. It's like 30 minutes till
closing and I just had this terrible
feeling. Something was really wrong.
Everyone seemed like they were almost
under a spell or almost like they
they all acted like this is fine. This
is okay. Something like this is normal.
And I was shocked and I just my appetite
had left me. And I just began to realize
as this cat, this white cat with with
yellow eyes
climbed up on my lap and up onto my
chest actually. and I kind of sat back
and just pet it and it brought a smile
to my face and I was the only one who
was petting a cat and I was enjoying it.
Everyone acted like I was weird. In
fact, they acted like I done something
wrong and someone told me, do not touch
the cat. Don't be nice to it. It's not
here to be nice to. You need to leave it
alone. And I was like, why? What is it
doing here? And no one seemed to answer
me, but they all acted like it just had
no rights. It had, you know, nothing
good attached to it. And I was just
loving on it. I spent the rest of my
time loving on that cat and decided
something occurred to me while I was
petting that cat and it was not a good
realization. I looked at the cake and
I just knew that there was blood in it.
There was blood from the animals and
there was blood from humans in it.
And as I was petting this cat,
I
realized all that and I had like this
image given to me in my mind where I
realized that
they had these machines that looked like
mailboxes. This image brought to me this
mailbox where you placed babies and
animals. And animals were only to be
used this way to dispense them inside of
the sacrifice machine here. that dumped
them down into a hole where they were
sacrificed and the blood was dispersed
to all major corporations and commercial
industries that made food. And I saw
this woman in that image doing that. And
she was she was putting a baby down the
mailbox and it was soundproof cuz
>> And it wasn't really a mailbox, right?
>> It actually looked very much like what
you have there, but it was not a
mailbox. just said basically, yeah, put
in your
baby or your sacrifice kind of thing.
And so I started, my stomach started
turning. I was not okay.
And I tried to get out of there as soon
as possible. It was closing. And I tried
to bring the cat with me, but I
couldn't. They told me I couldn't. And I
got out into the open mall area where I
knew that they wouldn't it probably get
away and could hide. But you did mention
that people would bring the baby
>> and the baby wouldn't even make a sound.
Almost like it was sedated and that's
right.
>> When it went in the box, there was no
sound. It was like a soundproof box and
then the person would just walk away
like nothing even happened. Right.
>> Yep.
And so I I was just um Yeah. I wasn't
okay. And I made myself get out of that
area very quickly. And I was still I'm
hungry. So I look out into this area. I
see this field full of corn and wheat.
In my dream it was also one side was
wheat, the other side was corn. And I I
spent time in both of them gleaning and
eating what I needed to out of it. And
when I was done eating, I took my time
to
go ahead and wander into the wilderness
up up in the mountains far beyond that.
And I just knew I could not live amongst
these people. I couldn't be around these
people. And
then my dream took me to 2047. So it's 2
years
before what my dream was showing me. And
it was still the same. Unfortunately,
everything
it wasn't exactly the same. It was a
little more
unmoddernized and and stuff, but it was
all the same stuff. And I started
realizing every I started realizing that
even Christians who are claiming to be
Christians are not Christian. They are
partaking of the system of the blood.
They were not
um
shocked or moved by it. They they acted
like everything was fine. And every
denomination I knew was a part of this.
And people from my own family,
unfortunately, extended family were
there. And
I was only one. I was alone.
Unfortunately, I had I did not have
Mikey there. I did not have any of my
family members, my immediate family
members there for that part of the
dream. And so I had to make my own way
alone
up into the mountain side to get away
and to live by myself for the rest of
the dream. And it cut off there. And
then I woke up. And so this is the full
dream. And this is quite the um
I don't know. I I guess that's all I
have to say. It's just really
disgusting. And I realized every system
throughout history has been the same.
All of the politicians, all the
celebrities, all of every denomination,
how they climb the ladder, all this
stuff has always been the same.
And so
I just I realized that when you follow
Christ and when you do things like the
way I wanted to live my life, I just
everything was wrong about it and I
couldn't put up with any of that. Okay.
>> So when she told me this dream, things
were coming to my mind
and um
it was really like
judgment day in the beginning at her
parents house. It was like everybody's
sins were being exposed like Adam and
Eve when they were in the garden. Like
they saw they noticed their nakedness.
They've been naked the whole time. They
were but there's going to be people that
are nitpicky and say they weren't
clothed with light and all this stuff.
Anyway, the Bible says that they realize
they were naked and they were ashamed
and they weren't ashamed before but some
their knowledge that of their sin or
their nakedness was revealed. So these
people at the house, some were
non-believers like my friends, some were
believers, and all of us realized we're
not worthy.
>> So, and I think that's really how it's
going to be when Christ returns. We're
all going to know. And, you know, in my
life over the years of repenting and
transformation and all that, the rest of
the world would look at me and say,
"Wow, man, you're like a saint or
something." But the closer I get to God,
the more unworthy I feel, the more
wretched I feel because
in comparison to him,
I'm I don't I'm no match. I'm not even
close to to worthy.
>> And so a lot of Christians today, they
feel like, well, I said the little
prayer when I was nine. I'm a Christian.
Nothing I can do can change that. No one
can pluck me out of the hand of God. And
so they just live like, I'm free. I'm
free in Christ. I can do whatever I want
to. I'm not under the law. All these
things, they just have this kind of
prideful attitude like I can live
however I want to and it doesn't matter.
Whereas me, I'm searching daily. Every
morning when we have worship together,
we're praying, Lord, forgive if there's
anything that we did, said, done, spoke
that offended you. Forgive us, Lord. We
want cast our sins as far as the east as
to the west. Help us overcome. help
[clears throat] us to overcome and pick
up our cross daily and live according to
your will. And I say that even when I
can't even think of anything because I I
know there are things
and um so that's what was happening in
the beginning I believe and then she was
taken to the future which 2049 I doubt
we're going to be around that long. I
don't feel like we are
>> but I think it was all symbolic.
Everybody's wearing white. They are all
self-righteous. They believe that
they're good and they're walking through
the Huh.
>> Most of the room from they were all
mostly people I knew
would proclaim themselves to be some
kind of Christian or Protestant
religion.
And then there was the people who were
kind of scattered and speckled in there
from acquaintances and people I know who
are atheists or completely against God.
um or even kind of a cult type people,
but
>> but probably feel like they're good
people or whatever. Yeah.
>> So,
>> so they're in this line of food, but
nobody's eating the real food. They all
just want the sweet dessert cake, and
they're actually peer pressuring Aubrey
into just move on. Like, you're stop
looking around. Just
>> get your cake and eat it.
And what they're not realizing is that
they're eating the cake with the blood
of the sacrifices of these people who
are in the industry. All the elites, all
this stuff is coming out now. Like, we
can actually talk about this stuff and
people don't think you're completely
nuts because these Epstein files are
coming out. But when you partake in
listening to secular music, you're
supporting the beast system. You're
supporting some artist that sold their
soul to Satan for that fame. When you're
watching porn, you're supporting
trafficking. When you're idolizing
Marilyn Manson or anyone else, you are
idolizing
wickedness.
And when you are consumed by materialism
and consumerism,
>> you're just it's vanity. And so even
these people that were living this
Christian life, the sins were coming up
in their life that didn't seem that
significant were really highlighted and
showing you are supporting the beast
system because even these clothing line
people, all the elites, all the people
that run these major corporations
have sold out. They've sold their souls.
And so finally Aubrey is taken to
the corn field where in the Bible Jesus
was with his disciples eating corn on
the Sabbath, you know, and uh he they
were accusing him and then she starts
heading towards the mountains. You and
the Bible talks about in the last days
flee to the mountains
>> and she's having to go alone. even her
personal close family. And that might
not be significant in the dream. It
might not be like your family's really
not going to make it. But it's showing
what Jesus said. If you love your
mother, your wife, your sister, your
brother more than me, then you're not
worthy. You have to leave it all. If it
comes down to it, now praise the Lord.
If your family is living right and
they're ready for Jesus' return, then
they're going to be with you. But you
have to be willing to sacrifice
everything in this life. everything, the
music, the movies, the the cake,
>> and even your family. If it has, there's
nothing this world has to offer. Nothing
that's worth missing out on eternity
with Christ in a perfect world. This
system is going to just get worse and
worse and worse to the point where we
we're living in the mark of the beast
system, and it's going to look like
peace and safety and unity and coexist
and all these things. But if you
compromise
from the word of God, then you're you've
compromised your salvation. He said,
'You either with me or you're against
me. If you love me, keep my
commandments. And this is why it's so
important for us to get in God's word
and to really study line upon line,
precept upon precept, understanding what
kind of things are coming in the future,
what prophetic events are happening.
Because the deception that's coming is
going to be so crafty and subtle that
it's going to deceive millions. Mhm.
>> Satan's going to appear as an angel of
light doing lying signs and wonders,
starting a whole religion that's based
on love and tolerance and unity, peace
and safety, and millions are going to be
deceived because they're not they're not
grounded. They're not standing on thus
sayeth the Lord, the word of God, and
understanding prophecy.
That's really all I have to say. There
are some scriptures that really I was I
was thinking of when she was telling me
this dream. But second Timothy 2 Timothy
4:3 and4 says, "For the time will come
when they will not endure sound
doctrine, but after their own lust shall
they heap themselves teachers having
itching ears, and they shall turn away
their ears from the truth, and shall be
turned unto fables." There's another
verse that says that in in the end times
that God will send them a strong
delusion because they had not a love of
the truth. When you don't love the
truth, God gives you over to your
reprobate mind. He gives you over to the
desires of the lust of your flesh and it
gives you that free will and allows you
to have what you're desiring. And in
that day, it'll be the strong delusion
because they didn't love the truth.
Hebrews 5:13-14
says, "For everyone who partakes only of
the milk is unskilled in the word of
righteousness, for he is a babe. But
solid food belongs to those who are of
full age." That is those who by reason
of use have their senses exercised to
discern both good and evil. That might
be a little confusing because King
Jamesy, but it's talking about
that when you first become a believer,
you're a babe in Christ. I mean, you're
you're hanging on to John 3:16 and and
little verses here and there, but as you
grow, you're supposed to evolve from the
milk, to the meat, to the solid food.
You can't go on years and years of your
Christian life just not growing, not
believe, not um understanding new
things. It's our responsibility to dig
for truth like gold in God's word. And
if you're not growing, you're stagnant.
We should never be stagnant in our walk
with Christ. It is a walk. It is a
growth. And if you're stagnant, there's
a problem. And you really need to take
it to the Lord and and I don't know
giving it some more effort on trying to
seek your relationship with God and
>> should ask him like you really need to
ask for him to come alive to you and
show himself to you and revive your
spirit because
I don't know Satan can really make you
feel dull and
>> like you can't do anything, you can't
feel anything and that's his aim. So
sometimes you need a new heart given to
you as well. And I've shared little a
little short version of my testimony
here recently and it was talking about
how,
you know, I wasn't reading God's word
for myself
and I'd go to church here and there and
I'd ask my cousin questions and that led
me way astray. I mean, I was getting
answers that I know were in the Bible,
but they were out of context or, you
know, only part of a scripture or
something, and it led me way out there
thinking that I was blessed by God and
he was opening up the doors for me to
have free beer and weed and all kinds of
stuff. So, you have to be in God's word
to truly understand and study it out
daily. Romans 12:2 says, "And be not
conformed to this world, but be ye
transformed by the renewing of your mind
that ye may prove what is that good and
acceptable and perfect will of God." So,
we can't just blend in with the crowd
like all those people in that cafeteria.
They had no fruits of the spirit. They
were gossiping, slandering, cussing,
being promiscuous with each other. And
they all thought they were good to go
because they didn't have a love of the
meat of the word of God. They were just,
"Give me the cake. Give me what tickles
my ears." They want to hear the sermons,
the the fluff, you know? They want to
hear, "Oh, God loves you. You're
beautiful." You know, I hate to name
drop, but Joe Ostein, you know, like
those are the sermons. Joe Ostein is
just a basically a Christian
motivational speaker. There's no call to
repentance. There's no
prophecy. There's nothing deep being
taught. It's all just like, "Let me tell
you why God loves you." And that's what
these people were looking for in the
dream. Just the cake.
And lastly, Ephesians 5:11, "And have no
fellowship with the unfruitful works of
darkness, but rather expose them."
That's why Aubrey was walking off to the
mountains by herself. She was leaving
what looked what appeared on the outside
to be good. You know, people all wearing
white and clean and they all professed
to be Christian,
but they had no fruit. And if we blend
in with that, then we have compromised
the truth and compromising our
salvation. And if you have to, you know,
Jesus told a parable. He didn't really
mean it, but he said, 'If your hand
offends you, cut it off. If your eye
offends you, pull it out. Have no
fellowship with the unfruitful works of
darkness. He says that light and dark
can't mix.
>> You cannot have light and darkness
mixing together. It talk the Bible
always talks about how bad fellowship
will will bring down good morals. It
very rarely is that you change that
person when there's like a whole Now,
we're called to be a light. We're called
to enter into the darkness and share the
truth, but we're not supposed to dwell
there and stay there and and always be a
part of it. You go in and you be a
light. Whether it's in the workplace,
most of us work in secular places. You
should have the fruits of the spirit
that people can recognize and they say,
"What is it about you?" You never get
angry. You never get stressed out. I
never hear hear you use foul language.
And you say, "Well, you know, that's
because I've been transformed. You know,
I invited Christ into my heart." But
those are situations where you're there
for a couple hours and you leave.
And so, we're not so we're not supposed
to just be a part of the world. In the
world, but not of the world. I hope this
was a blessing to you guys. Like we
said, we're not trying to say that
Aubrey is a prophet or anything, but
that dream to me and my friend and
hopefully some of you guys had some very
significant biblical principles in
there. And I think it was really
revealing the signs of the times that
we're living in, how we should not be
partaking in anything that supports this
wicked, evil beast system that is all
around us. And and you know when Christ
returns, if Christ were to were return
today, nobody could say, "I didn't
know."
>> Everything is coming out. Everything's
coming to light. And I do believe we
have a video on the Epstein Files. Go
watch it. I believe that Satan is doing
this. Satan is allowing all this to come
out for his own plan to bring humanity
to a state of hopelessness so that when
he appears as a cosmic savior, we'll all
embrace him. But at the same time, it's
like a a a double-edged sword. The truth
is coming out, and now it's up to us to
look at that truth and turn from these
wicked things and stop supporting it.
So, if you appreciate this, if this was
a blessing to you, please give it a
thumbs up. Really helps get this video
out into the algorithm. Leave us a
comment. Let us know if there was
something about this dream that made
sense to you. I actually saw people in
the comments saying they had a similar
dream or I couldn't read them all, but I
want to know what you guys think. Tell
us in the comment section. If you would
like to support this ministry, you can
do so by going to candidtruth.org. We
got Cash App, Vinmo, Zel, PayPal. We
even have Patreon.
And we also have clothes. We got
merchandise. We get about $5 on every
sale, whether it's a mug or a hoodie or
a t-shirt. And we got a lot of cool
t-shirts on there and it really helps
us. If you guys have been giving, we
thank you so much. We see you. We love
you and we thank you and we try to give
everybody feedback, but certain
platforms like Zel won't even let us
respond. So, we just want to let you
know that we thank you and we love you.
And if you want to support this
ministry, we actually are putting out
new literature. This is a a track that
talks about the UFO deception that's
about to come upon this earth. And I'm
going to play an ad for that right now
so you can find out how to give to that
so that this can be a free resource to
anyone that wants this literature to
pass out. And we'll see you next time on
Candid Truth. If you guys didn't know,
Trump just said that he's about to
disclose UFOs. President Trump announced
Thursday [music] evening that he would
be directing relevant agencies to
release files on aliens and [music]
UFOs.
>> Knowing what we know as Bible believing
Christians that this is Satan's final
masquerade. There are millions of people
out there who have no idea what's
coming. All they know is that the
military is telling them that aliens are
real and [music] they're here and
they're among us.
>> Biologics came with some of these
recoveries.
>> Were they, I guess, human or non-human
biologics?
>> Non-human. And that was the assessment
of people uh with direct knowledge on
the program I talked to.
>> We are going to get 20,000 of these
printed and hopefully we'll get more.
This says [music] top secret UFO
disclosure in Bible prophecy. It's
analog so you don't need the internet or
electricity and you can put it right in
somebody's hands and it's concise and
straightforward and gets right to the
point. Printing isn't cheap, but we got
a great deal on these prints from a
personal friend of mine in California.
So, with your help, we can get 20,000 or
more of these printed if you just click
on the donation link below to help us
expose the lies before it's [music] too
late.